[Music]
on this sunday night
the big hit for small businesses the
bottom line
before they bottom out and it's nearly
impossible to move
all those sales to online the economic
crisis as christmas
approaches the rent subsidy revamped
finally eight months into the pandemic
could this be the relief for businesses
on the edge of bankruptcy
plus the hills are alive with skiers but
how do they
socially distance and getting disney to
get indigenous roles
right actively trying to
bring more diversity to their content
the canadian producer
shaking things up in hollywood
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with breaking news
and another record shattered in alberta
that province is now reporting the
highest daily number of coven 19 cases
than
anywhere else in canada alberta recorded
nearly 1600 cases today
a record for the fourth day in a row and
that's more than ontario which has three
times the population
that province had more than fifteen
hundred cases today
we're on the cusp of the holiday season
but so many of our plans are on hold
provinces are
either implementing more restrictions or
going into lockdown
and caught in the middle businesses
struggling to meet the bottom line
as global's marnie blunt reports it may
be too late to pivot
to save them
the holiday shopping season looks a lot
different this year
with many canadian stores under lock and
key
well it impacts it greatly and i just
have to pivot i have to move
in a different direction and and do what
i can to
keep my business going i've been doing a
lot of virtual appointments with people
where i actually take them around
my store with my phone in manitoba
businesses can stay open
to sell essential items only and the
province has taken
extra measures to make sure big box
stores that remain open
can't skirt the rules remember that the
right to shop
is not as important as the right to life
but in quebec
shoppers filled the streets sunday
lining up outside stores
we have nothing else to do you know with
corona so
we're just going out on sundays having
fun you know honestly it's pretty busy
and most people are wearing masks so
it's not too bad on monday toronto and
the nearby peel region joined manitoba
in banning in-store shopping for
non-essential items
forcing many businesses to rely solely
on online sales
over the key holiday shopping season it
basically it's a lose-lose for everyone
in manitoba right now and it's a win for
the amazons of the world the retail
council of canada says pivoting to
online sales
is easier said than done for many
businesses
they still rely on their brick and
mortar store
and it's nearly impossible to move all
those sales
to online industry experts say right now
the best way to help is by shopping
local this holiday season
and doing your part to ensure the virus
gets under control
and these businesses can open their
doors once again robin
marnie blount in winnipeg thanks marnie
tomorrow a new aid program goes into
effect in a bid to save businesses on
the brink
the rent subsidy was first introduced in
april but it was up to landlords to
apply
now the federal government has changed
the rules to make tenants eligible
david aiken explains the federal
government has left
lockdown decisions up to local health
officials
while promising to be the financial
backstop for those affected
by lockdown decisions the federal
government
will be there as we have since the
beginning to support
those communities those individuals
those small businesses
and to that end ottawa has a new program
to help businesses charities and
non-profits
pay the rent applications open monday
finally eight months into the pandemic
canada finally has a decent rent support
program
the new canada emergency rent subsidy is
aimed at providing rent
and mortgage interest relief directly to
commercial tenants and property owners
organizations can apply to revenue
canada for a subsidy of up to
65 percent of eligible expenses incurred
from september forward
and those organizations closed because
of a public health order
can qualify for a 25 top up
effectively giving them a 90 subsidy
that is good news it will make the
difference uh
in terms of allowing some firms to uh to
get through
what we expect to be just a brutal
december for so
many small firms the new rent subsidy
program will run at least until next
june though
there may be changes in the new year but
more may be needed
and opposition politicians in ottawa
will push for those changes this week in
the house of commons
i absolutely believe that the public
health advice to stay at home is
essential
but what that public health advice has
to be coupled with is
an understanding of the reality that
people are faced with business groups
say
the rent subsidy program can be improved
by making it
retroactive to the spring the number one
question we're getting from small
business owners is
great that my my go-forward rent may be
partly covered
but what do i do with the hundred
thousand dollars worth of rent debt
that is still haunting me as a business
owner and even with the improved
business aid programs
the canadian federation of independent
business believes as many as
two hundred thousand small businesses
will be forced to shut their doors for
good
before this pandemic ends david aiken
global news
ottawa you only have to look to nunavut
to see how quickly covet 19 can spread
just over two weeks ago the territory
had no cases
now there are 128. in the last
24 hours alone nunavut recorded 21 new
cases
most of them are in the community of
arviat arviat a hamlet of 2600 people
now has a total of 98 coven 19
infections there are also new cases in
rankin inlet
and whale cove we have been warned
against non-essential travel but hawaii
wants to form a bubble with canada
the aloha state is extending a
pre-testing travel
program so canadians can vacation there
without a 14-day quarantine
michael couture explains how it works
every year about half a million
canadians visit the picturesque beaches
of hawaii
kovid 19 closed borders for
non-essential travel between canada and
the united states but residents of our
country
will soon be allowed back to the aloha
state
beginning in mid-december travelers
flying from canada to hawaii
may bypass the state's 14-day quarantine
if they take the coven 19 test
from labs identified by
air canada and westjet the key
is those rapid tests travelers will have
to get a negative result within 72 hours
of departure to avoid quarantine when
they arrive
westjet has partnered with dynalife labs
the same company that did all of the
testing for the nhl bubble
obviously it's not as many flights as
you would have liked
ten directs or nine pardon me directs
per week um pre-covered we would have
had a lot more
traffic but we think this is a really
good step in the in the right direction
i certainly have come into about 50
emails so far this morning
canadian travel consultant claire
newell's inbox is already flooded with
interested travelers
she believes rapid testing is the key to
helping the airline industry
take off again it's going to be
necessary moving forward
especially with things like cruising but
we
are a little bit behind some of the
other countries
lufthansa airlines has started a trial
with free rapid testing for all
passengers on flights between munich and
hamburg germany
canada's agreement with hawaii creates a
kind of travel bubble
with the state mainland usa and japan
were part of the original test run in
october
despite allowing visitors hawaii remains
the state with the lowest per capita
incidents of covet 19.
and while the governor admits allowing
more visitors could create an uptick in
cases
he says they are creating travel bubbles
within hotels
and other destinations so that should
someone
after arrival become ill or symptomatic
that we can provide them health care be
able to test them
if needed and then most importantly able
to isolate and quarantine them
and travel consultants say your last
layer of protection
is to buy health insurance just in case
you get sick
while on vacation mike lacouter global
news
the speed at which new cases are
multiplying in the united states is
unsettling
as of today there are 12.2 million cases
confirmed in that country
nearly one quarter of those infections
emerged in november
before that it took just over two weeks
for cases to jump from eight
to nine million by october 30th by
november 9th
there were 10 million seven days after
that 11 million
and less than a week to add another 1
million infections the situation has
left hospitals and morgues
overwhelmed several states have imposed
new restrictions
including california where a curfew went
into effect last night
but as jennifer johnson reports members
of the coronavirus task force
have set the ambitious target of rolling
out a vaccine
by mid-december
in california angry residents took to
the streets to find the latest
restrictions that ban non-essential work
and gatherings after 10 pm
an illegal curfew 10 o'clock curfew
we're not going to abide by it
it's ridiculous to further try and stop
the rapid spread of covet 19
it's now an early last call for bars
desperate for business
we were staying open until midnight to
try to get a little bit of that
bar crowd but that is not the case
anymore
in minnesota hundreds of protesters
demonstrated outside governor tim wahl's
home
after he ordered gyms to close youth
sports to stop at bars and restaurants
to do takeout only
angry protests in washington state too
after the centers for disease control
recommended americans stay home this
holiday season
we're going to have thanksgiving with
our family and you're not going to tell
us otherwise
governors across the u.s forced to take
drastic measures again
as new cases of coven 19 dramatically
spike air force medical personnel and
the texas national guard
have been deployed to overwhelmed el
paso hospitals
and the local morgue we hit the ground
running and started working in some of
the critical care sections in the
emergency medicine rooms a lot of the
people i work with have described it
similar to afghanistan iraq the federal
government is fast tracking a new cobot
19 vaccine hoping health care workers
could get the first dose
by mid-december on the 11th or on the
12th of december
hopefully the first people will be
immunized across the united states
across all states
but u.s president donald trump is still
blocking the transition of
president-elect joe biden
there's a lot of focus on that vaccine
rollout plan that's going to be critical
in the early days
of abiding presidency we have no access
to that no official response on that
from the white house but the head of
president trump's
operation warp speed says he's been told
not to disclose confidential information
to
anyone outside the present
administration
jennifer johnson global news washington
british prime minister boris johnson has
revealed plans to end the uk's four-week
lockdown
next month the united kingdom has the
worst death toll from kova 19 in europe
more than 54 000 people have died
beginning december 2nd there will be a
return to the three-tiered system of
restrictions
areas will face different measures
depending on the severity
of their outbreaks christmas is not
going to be
normal this year but that said the prime
minister and everyone else were looking
at ways to see
how families can spend some time with
each other over christmas period
obviously that's something that we would
like to do
the prime minister's office confirmed
plans to begin a nationwide vaccination
program next month assuming regulators
approve a covet-19 vaccine
prime minister justin trudeau joined his
g20 counterparts in pledging
vaccine access to all to ensure poorer
countries aren't left behind in the
rollout
the virtual summit hosted by saudi
arabia wrapped up with a promise to
extend
debt relief to developing nations also
on the agenda
looking ahead to the post-pandemic
economic recovery
and tackling the climate crisis as the
u.s prepares for new leadership
president donald trump officially
withdrew the u.s from the paris climate
agreement earlier this month
and today he defended the move in
prepared remarks
to protect american workers i withdrew
the united states from the unfair and
one-sided
paris climate accord a very
unfair act for the united states the
paris accord was not designed to save
the environment that was designed to
kill
the american economy trump didn't take
part in yesterday's virtual session
which focused on the global response to
the covet 19 pandemic
instead he spent the day on his golf
course as he did again
today coming up social distancing
and skiing how to manage the crowds on
the hills
and later a canadian producer is working
with disney
to stop stereotyping indigenous roles
a blast of winter hit toronto today as
the low pressure system moves through
ontario
between 10 to 20 centimeters of snow
fell across the city
right before it heads into lockdown
tomorrow other regions of ontario saw up
to 30 centimeters of snowfall
quebec is now bracing for snow as the
system moves into that province
overnight
it's been a busy start to ski season at
a number of canadian resorts
take a look at sunshine village in
alberta
oh my god it is back all the way to here
the ticket lines wrapped through the
parking lot the resort says it will now
limit capacity
it shows the pent-up demand for skiers
who had their ski season cut short when
the pandemic hit in march
heather yorks west shows us how ski
hills are preparing to cope
with crowds faced with the prospect of a
winter cooped up inside
the call of the mountains has perhaps
never been so loud
excited to you know get outside and do
some fun and have some winter fun and
have our seasons passes and
just ready to be out of the house it's
early in the season and ski hills that
have opened so far
are seeing demand this year is high the
weather cooperated
people want to come out so people are
coming in heaps
and they want to ski they want to have
fun they want to forget about all the
madness what's going on in the city
most people who ski and snowboard here
at nakiska are from alberta
but destination hills like lake louise
and whistler rely a lot more on
international travelers and this year
those travelers won't be able to come
with the borders closed you know we're
obviously not getting the u.s and
international guests that we had in the
past
but the increased interest in the local
market certainly i think will probably
make up for it
ski and board shops are noticing the
increased demand too
this calgary business has seen sales
rise 300 percent
over last year we're seeing anywhere
from brand new skiers and boarders
getting their
first sets of gear to like snowbirds
that aren't going south this year and
decide to dust off the skis get them
tuned up and get their first seasons
past they've had in
several years but while skiers may be
seeking an escape from the pandemic even
on the slopes the threat of covet 19
is still very much top of mind resorts
like vancouver's grouse mountain require
guests wear masks
and are operating lifts at reduced
capacity you will need to
reserve your sky skyride time in advance
you can do that online we are also
recommending online ticket purchases
tents and other temporary structures are
also being used to ensure people can
warm up while keeping distant
operators hoping that the measures
they've taken will help them remain open
through the season
so that pandemic weary canadians have
some place safe to play
heather your ex-west global news
kananaskis alberta
still ahead the budget cuts that set off
theory in guatemala
a wave of anger and unrest in guatemala
tonight
thousands of protesters took to the
streets after the government passed a
new budget
that will cut spending for health care
and education some demonstrators broke
into congress and set one part of the
building on fire
they say the budget was negotiated in
secret while the public was distracted
by back-to-back hurricanes
and the pandemic ethiopia's prime
minister
abi ahmed is giving rebel leaders in
tigray 72 hours to surrender peacefully
before troops and tanks surround the
region's capital
ethiopian forces are preparing a major
assault against the tigray people's
liberation front
if they don't lay down their arms the
military is warning civilians caught in
the crossfire to save themselves now
because there will be no mercy for the
rebel leaders who are accused of hiding
among the general population
more than 36 thousand refugees have fled
tigre into neighboring sudan
since the conflict broke out earlier
this month
ethnic armenians in nagorno-karabakh
paid respects to the fallen today as
they pick up the pieces following a
six-week war
hundreds possibly thousands of lives
were lost after heavy fighting between
armenia and azerbaijan in the breakaway
region
the enclave is situated within
azerbaijan's borders
but is largely populated by ethnic
armenians
a russia brokered ceasefire saw
azerbaijan take back control of
territory it seized during the conflict
today russian peacekeepers transported
drinking water and other aid
to residents in remote parts of the
region as part of the agreement to end
the hostilities
russia deployed about 2 000 troops to
ensure the truce
holds up next indigenous representation
with a hollywood powerhouse we'll
explain when global national returns
it's not every day you get to work with
one of hollywood's most powerful players
but a small production company
has teamed up with disney to shed light
on indigenous youth
the company's ceo jacob pratt comes from
a saskatchewan first nation
now he's seizing a rare opportunity for
indigenous representation
within the entertainment industry brady
ratzlaff explains
jacob pratt loves to tell stories
through the lens of a camera hi
his team at skoda entertainment in
california recently signed a big deal
with an even bigger company
we were just getting up and running and
we landed disney as our first major
client
that deal provided the platform for
pratt and his team to create
three mini episodes featuring indigenous
youth
one way that we make a difference is
through our art as part of native
american heritage month which is
celebrated in the u.s
every november we wanted to share each
one of those stories because they're so
different
but also they're
all advocates for indigenous cultures
and
social justice pratt was born on the
cote first nation in saskatchewan
but grew up in the george gordon first
nation he completed his business degree
in regina
before making the move to los angeles to
pursue a career in the entertainment
industry
pratt says disney is working to move
away from its past reputation of
stereotyping some cultures
and this new deal is a way to bring more
indigenous material to the table that
portrays his people in an authentic way
they've come a long ways as an
organization
and have acknowledged their shortcomings
of in the past
and have been actively trying to um
bring more diversity to their content
which is great
for everybody he says the episodes are
part of a series called use your voice
for young people that are making
differences and
trying to make a change within their
community are being featured
and their stories are being shared
members of his team say it's pratt's
attention to detail and passion for
storytelling
that makes him a great person to
collaborate with we both
had kind of the same goals and
aspirations as far as
telling stories in the in the creative
space pratt says there are ongoing
discussions with disney for more content
the episodes air on the disney channel
and youtube
brady ratzlaff global
and that is global national for this
sunday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is lower island cove
in conception bay north
newfoundland and labrador we'd love to
see your part of the country so email
your photos to viewers at
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be at the anchor desk tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]
you